now to chile where voters have
overwhelmingly rejected a progressive
new constitution in a referendum the
proposed constitution was aimed at
boosting the rights of indigenous people
and women it would have been replaced or
would have replaced rather the one
adopting
adopted during the pinochet era chile's
current president has vowed to press
ahead with efforts to overhaul the
constitution
more than 60 percent of people who cast
their ballots voted against the rewrite
victory for the no camp
chilean voters rejected the proposed new
constitution by a far wider margin than
polls predicted they said no to what
would have been one of the most
progressive constitutions in the world
with a focus on social welfare gender
equality environmental protection and
indigenous rights
it is a really surprising triumph and
that means chile is a country that
rejects communism marxism and the
attempt of communism
to seize
at power emblematic italy square there's
disappointment for backers of the new
constitution
after strong initial support polls
showed the yes campaign losing momentum
in recent weeks with voters worried
about market instability and how to pay
for new benefits
observers also point to a disinformation
campaign
leftist president borac is vowing to go
back to the drawing board
i make an honest appeal to all political
forces to put chile ahead of any
differences they may have
and to agree as soon as possible on the
deadlines and parameters of a new
constitutional process
for now chile is left with the 1980
constitution drawn up under the
dictatorship of augusto pinochet
center-left and right-wing parties that
supported the no campaign have agreed to
negotiate to prepare a new text
for more let's bring in miriam garrick
our latin america expert in bond miriam
the new constitution is regarded as more
well what would have been the new
constitution was regarded as more
progressive and inclusive why have
people voted against it
yes terry would have been the one of the
most progressive constitutions in the
world as you said i think it
might be that this constitution was even
too progressive chile is considered a
very conservative country
which you can see in even if they have a
left government left
president parliament congress is
dominated by the right-wing forces and
the exception was this constitutional
convention which was elected uh in may
2021 with a vast majority of left civil
society representatives and the
conservative parties didn't even reach a
third of the
seats in this convention so this kind of
promoted a mistrust in the text and the
work of the constitutional convention
also was looked at with very critical
eyes and they also produced some
negative headlines so i think there was
um it was maybe a two big step ahead to
transform chile into a new country
unfortunately
a big step and a big document i mean the
constitution is is hugely complicated
how well-informed
was the population about the details of
this new constitution were voters
subjected to much misinformation
indeed they were uh the conservative
parties and and those who opposed to
this new project really uh they run a
massive campaign on social media with
fake news
misinformation uh and misinterpretation
of what the
constitution proposed let's take some
examples for example you mentioned
the abortion was supposed to be
legalized by this new constitution the
opponents to the new constitution made
out of this that abortion would be
legalized up to the ninth month of
pregnancy in chile which is definitely
false
also they argued that private property
would be
forbidden and people would get would be
expropriated by their private homes for
example
even things like the national anthem and
the national flag would be abolished so
there was a lot of misinformation and
people were targeted by social media uh
there is a deep mistrust in chile in
both political institutions like parties
but also in traditional media and
ironically it was really traditional
media and state bodies like the um
yeah the government for example who run
an information campaign to really make
people familiar with the text but the
text itself with 70 178 pages is way too
long to really understand it
william thank you very much that was
dw's latin america expert miriam garcon
you